un dollar en baisse le terrorisme en
europe une concurrence de plus en plus
vives
les raisons d'inquiétude ne manquent pas
à air france où l'année 1986 a été
marquée par une diminution de 3 5% du
nombre de passagers kilomètre transporté
malgré ces difficultés la compagnie
nationale affiche pour l'année écoulée
un bénéfice net de 580 millions de
francs et elle se tourne résolument vers
l'avenir
en achetant 16 boeing 747-400 pour un
montant de 2 milliards de dollars
ne pouvant plus abritée d'ailleurs une
situation de monopole et face aux
nouvelles réglementations qui à partir
de 1992 rendront la concurrence encore
plus forte qu'aujourd'hui
air france est obligée de prendre les
devants elle le fait en investissant
c'est bien mais est-ce que ce sera
suffisant face à des compagnies
européennes ou américaines déjà beaucoup
plus compétitive